this is scott and kenny has it gotten uh
has it gotten a little annoying can he
just pass the annoyment what is fast
annoying
wasn't it better when they were just
sniping at each other
hey listen we were just first of all
y'all need to stop it
i never had it man i never started
haters i would sit here you're the one
who started it
contribution goes more than the stat
sheet
triple single
so you started i never said that i never
i've never had any kind of beef and you
started to beef and i didn't do this
i've seen triple single on my instagram
too many times
way too many times of what you've seen
from the phoenix suns a team that you
see a lot playing out there on the on
the west coast and obviously devin
booker everybody knows him but this is a
team that's going down there and and
gone four and oh so far it's great to
see book playing well and phoenix
playing well but get my man out of
phoenix
it's not good for him it's not good for
his career sorry chuck but uh wow they
got to get booked out of phoenix i need
my man to go somewhere where he can play
great basketball all the time and win
because he's that type of player are you
tampering
maybe
he's not a great shooter he's a great
defender but you have to honor yourself
with kimba and that opens up things for
haywood brown and tatum when you have a
player out there
who's who can't shoot or who's not a
great shooter teams know you can cheat
off of that guy and that's going to make
it harder on those guys if kimball's not
there we know
shots shut huh throwing shots
taking shots at me oh no no no no
come on man what are you talking about
i thought the same thing when i heard it
oh that sounds like i thought the same
thing we're talking about marcus smart
uh it's hey you said guys sounds sound
very similar to draymond green all right
there may be a little crack in here
great do not let kenny come between us
i'm telling you i heard the same thing
see now you're searching kenny my
eyebrow went up just like his ryan
well
both of y'all are speaking on the
defense which i think is 100 accurate
but when i look at this stat sheet the
thing that jumps out to me and i know pg
was in foul trouble
reggie jackson was six for 12 from three
now in to reggie jackson credit he
knocked his shots down but reggie
jackson can't beat six for 12 from three
and paul george is seven for 14 from the
floor
that that is the dallas mavericks
executing their game plan which which
everyone's just saying get the ball out
of luke and half they're saying hey pg
we want the ball out of your hands we
want reggie jackson shooting at three
we're going to make reggie jackson beat
us because we know paul george can beat
us we know kawhi leonard can beat us so
what what y'all are saying
that
uh the clippers need to do the dallas
that is exactly what dallas is doing to
the clippers let's make everybody else
beat us
that goes back to your point
if the dallas mavericks had five guys
and double figures i don't know if they
beat the clippers
the ball is spread out that means when
it's crunch time the guy who might have
the ball the most wouldn't have it
possibly yeah but you can't let the
nicest player on the on the court have a
rhythm taking 37 shots it ain't like
he's nine for three through 17 for 30
seconds he's shooting fade aways calling
people out
catching catching got a double i mean
not just look at any nba great player
who can score ernie
you have to double them when they're
rolling like there's nobody steph curry
gets rolling you got to double james
dame lilly gets rolling he got to double
him there's no nba player that can
really score the ball that you can
continue to play one-on-one and get
through screens let's wrap this up the
way we started it then when you're with
your recollections of 95 so when you
finally break through
uh and you know
you come back for game six in your place
ice cream because you you like my always
my saying your antennas are up like you
know no we're not doing that again we're
not doing that again we're not going
back like santa we were like telling the
ball boys when we were leaving hey see
you guys next year they were like what
are you talking about oh cause we're not
coming back we won't see you this year
see you next year oh have a good summer
that's it we we're telling everybody in
arena we're never coming back there
dallas they will never come back to los
angeles dallas has the lead guarantee
over the clippers
you have too many championships to
activate this button
you you have too many snappers
but you can put it on a sticky note
sorry you have too many championships to
activate this button
try it one more time let's see what else
you got sorry you do not eat enough
doughnuts to activate this button
there you go okay now we got dre three
three yeah three two three four
three-time nba championship rings
nine
you
rings
and as a professional you gotta always
stay ready and i knew that last series
of small ball
and coach had already told us that it's
gonna be a tough plus to get minutes
because of how houston plays
so you know instead of you know getting
upset
you know just
howling you know just
decided to just go
go get ready for this this series
against where we played next and happen
to be different
so i'm just very thankful that i got an
opportunity to get out there and play
and i wanted to give my teammates
everything i got
and just pushed the limit
what was the key for you guys
dwight howard after the lakers game one
victory you like the hoodie
no the hoodie was trash
i mean it was like cut a little too high
maybe like wearing a hoodie in the
middle of this dwight come on
all about closing out quarters 13-6 run
by the utah jazz to close out the
quarter
in memphis
donovan mitchell
got 14. utah seeking a 3-1 lead in this
series
memphis giving them all they can handle
59-54 is the halftime score american
express halftime report ernie johnson
charles barkley kenny the jet smith
draymond green in for shaquille o'neal
tonight and we jump on the american
express teammates right off the bat
spider mitchell got 14. jordan clarkson
six man of the year
has got 12
4 out of 10 from the floor hit a couple
of threes he's been struggling from
distance in this series
utah hitting 10 out of 19 from the
promised land in the first half
and uh
draymond you know
all about being on a team that loves a
three-pointer absolutely utah's been
living and dying by the three all year
and
they've mostly lived right and tonight
they're doing the same thing again
donovan mitchell connecting there
mitchell two out of five from deep and
again utah with the lead by 5 59 to 54.
uh you're both kind of looking at
grizzlies so kenny i'll start with you
uh you got your eye on john marin i have
my
or is that just part of the story no
well i i just call him the package
come on come on come on oh no
i told you see that's never any fun no
that's never enough no
in a previous visit you did the same
come on i told you man i've only i
didn't want no
i told you i didn't want no smoking oh
dude's in the league right now it just
seemed like he stopped catching hey
catch me in the 90s out of got you but
anyway
but i'll tell you one thing he's
becoming the package and chucky said one
thing i think he said the one thing in
the back where you're talking and said
he's got to get a better jump shot if he
gets his jump shot yeah it's going to be
over but his jump shot is starting to
improve and he's he's now when guys are
going under the screen and they're
trying to make him and force him to do
things the one thing he does now he's
saying you know what if you give me too
much space i will
just raise up the first part of making
shots is attempting him he wasn't
attempting those shots early in his
career now he's tempting him now the
second part is so he got the three ball
so now you isolate and everyone loves
the switch so you want to have rudy go
bear guard him you say well rudy
gobert's got me so you think he's going
to pull up for three again but know the
package he's got the left hand the right
hand and he's got all the trick layups
so he got the three ball of layups the
nba analytics love that so now the last
part of the game that you gotta have on
the offensive end especially at the
point guard business freeze it it's the
floater so if you got the floater in
here that's the giant killer see how
rudy both bear is dead man in the air
that's a giant killer right there so you
got all of those
if you got all those i'm gonna practice
i'm practicing okay i'm gonna need a
little more practice i'll get you this
week i'm not i'm not here tomorrow but
i'm here with you buddy
sprint coach by wednesday yeah i'm
working on it jaws only 28 in the second
game and here he's got eight on two of
seven in the first half but again the
mindset that you point out now you're
next in line you know we we talked about
it uh draymond like about having guys
do
like what the game plan is we always
start the game plan
geez kenny
[Laughter]
you you know what you have spent the
last
half of basketball thinking about that
moment
yeah where's your mic man
[Music]
[Laughter]
a picture of humiliation
here in studio jay
calling rob
calling rob calling audio rob
here give me that if there was no stairs
i would have got him it's beautiful is
it working gets beat going to the board
knocks his audio out okay still give us
your pictures
here's the pictures we could do but the
one thing is you know when you talk
about lupus they were saying we don't
want to switch now so we want to keep
our best defenders on it but right now
reggie jackson gets lost on the on the
screen but luke is like freezing here
i'm going to go through i'm running a
double they learn a high double high
pick and roll to create switches but
paul george does a good job of getting
through it so he gets through and now
you got your best defender on it no
we're going to try to get zupak in it
but paul draws fights over again and
lucas says you know what i could take
him too and so the best defenders are
now getting the blunt of the work here's
platoon best defender no you're not the
best defender i don't need a screen for
you again we got our best defenders
we're not gonna freeze it here we're not
gonna put zubac in it but he's not gonna
let rondo get back around you're too
little young man you're too little young
man so now i get into the lane and
floater so the clippers game plan
actually is decent to say we're going to
keep the truck
hey y'all can't this guy's in the league
all defensive player i was out see if
there was no stairs if there was no
stairs i would have had oh these dance
killed me
you got you got to the stairs when he
got to the wall so the stairs had
nothing to do with it no i can't go up
the stairs
[Laughter]
tell him john and there's no shame in
losing to the all-defensive player man
and i'm and i'm sure 35 year old rajon
rondo appreciates you calling him young
man yeah yeah yeah well i think one
issue though is
who in the media is reporting and
reporting this and who off that team
said this to you because i actually had
a very similar situation happen with me
with steve kerr in
i want to say i believe it is
where we had an argument in the locker
room in okc and yet you know there's a
reporter standing in the hallway and
hear it and then reports on it why are
you reporting something that's not being
reported to you you're standing outside
that's almost eavesdropping no one's
talking to you you're standing outside
of a locker room and then you're
reporting what you hear at the door
that's ridiculous your job is to report
but then that was
that person reporting that there were
that two guys hadn't had had words and
why does that matter locker room is a
sacred place it's a safe place for
players if players that's that's a
closed door we didn't argue in front of
you on the court that's what you report
you don't go report what's happening
behind a closed door in our locker room
because the walls may not be thick
enough for the door isn't thick enough
and you can hear you report what's being
told to you or what you see on the floor
your report is something you can't even
see none of the questions
who said what you think the question
would be like
draymond i overheard something
can you elaborate on what was going on
and then he's reporting on that exactly
but to say i heard
this through a wall
i would have to agree with that's not
reporting that's eavesdropping you can't
put a name to a face how can you report
that you have really have no you know
like sometimes you hear yelling
screaming you have no idea what they're
yelling and screaming about yeah and
that's and that's when you ask that's
why you say hey look we're standing out
here and it sounded loud in here it
sounded like without question guys we're
going at each other
but what jason tatum say that's that's
the perfect answer to me we don't bring
our locker room stuff out to the public
right no i do have something to say
about chuck let it go you know everyone
thinks winning championships is peaches
and creams it's not
you're going to have these disputes
you're going to have these arguments
and a lot of times it's not the leader
you know the teams that i played for of
course i was i was an arguer but brian
shaw rick fox would say some big shot
bob uh to say something uh draymond you
know he's not the best player until no
disrespect but he's the guy that's
always vocal he's the heart and soul of
the team so you know sometimes you know
these things are good but you know the
media like they want to play like it's a
problem
having a heated discussion is never a
problem like you know people ask me all
the time you know chuck i have here it's
good but it's not a problem it's all
about respect so as long as you got the
respect thing there you can say what you
want to say you know sometimes you know
you have to call a guy out sometime a
guy has to call you out for you to no
recognize so i know what that's about
because i got four championships and it
was never easy and it was never hey
ernie how's it how's your wife it was
never that it was you know going back
and forth he said something i say
something i don't like you today
whatever whatever but as long as the
respect is there
none of that stuff yeah and etiquette is
different ernie last thing i'll put it
and put a ball in it the etiquette is
different in an nba or nfl or sports
locker room than the etiquette is at tnt
tara august who's back there who our
boss said she came out and said the same
things that
a head coach would say and say would say
it hr would be down here she'd be gone
everybody here
it's a different environment so a head
coach is talking and a player is talking
in a much different manner which has
never been said to me in this
environment somebody tried to say
something like that in this environment
here like it would be a whole different
animal
so but in a locker room environment you
look at it differently and you're also
taking it in differently but you're
reporting it as you're in a hr
environment in terms of
at your job at your at usa today or espn
it doesn't happen the same way you know
what's really funny
when i was watching the last dance
and you know you because we all get
together watch it and we're smoking and
drinking and watching it and we're like
smoking water
drinking cigars
i don't know
wait wait wait
wait
that cracked me calling you chocolate
the last dance taught me one thing
going back to when i first got to the
nba and they're like hey young fella
whatever happens in the locker room
stays in the locker room but the thing
that was funny about the last days
those guys hated each other
uh you had all these different
coaches and general managers hating each
other and that team won six
championships
i always tell people i said those dudes
won six championship and they hated each
other can you imagine on the crappy nba
teams how much stuff be going on behind
the scenes that's why you have to keep
stuff in the locker room i know but the
reality is though i think winning teams
argue way more than losing teams because
losing teams they bicker so if i'm on a
losing team i'm gonna come to you ernie
and say hey man shaq ain't passing me
the ball and he frees me out and then
you partner up with me and now me and
you looking at shaq like he's crazy a
winning team is going to say
jason your body language was terrible in
the first quarter because that's what i
saw when i was watching the game their
offense is on the run they're up a
couple points and he's not touching the
ball and he's dropping his shoulders but
you're the best player on the team so
yes i'm going to say something about
that winning teams will always argue
more than losing teams and in fact you
know the media can love losing teams if
they want if they don't want any
argument and those teams will just lose
and that's that